well with the team thousands of miles
away in Florida it was good vibes only
at the Las Vegas ballpark tonight where
fans gathered to watch the game a lot of
fans 8 news now reporter Madison
Kimbrough is in the middle of all that
action she joins us from Summerlin
tonight
it really was a sense of community here
at the Las Vegas ballpark Smiles all
around as fans were certain that we were
going to take home another win in game
four
Vegas golden Knight fans line the
ballpark Saturday to watch the Stanley
Cup Final up on the big screen
many expressing how impactful the
knights have been to the Vegas Community
they came to us in our darkest time it
put smiles on our faces again feels like
we're a family like we're you know and
we're a part of something big it just it
feels really good
and to see all these people come here to
support you know our team that's the
best
[Music]
the Las Vegas ballpark opened its doors
around 4 pm to a sold-out crowd as the
venue was packed and in the end the
knights prevailed it's just absolutely
electric it is just the most incredible
feeling but the job's not finished yet
we got one more to go and then we're
Crown Champions the enthusiasm and the
support of all those thousands of people
at the same time I I know they can't
hear us you know the team but
it felt like maybe we were extending
that energy to them the Las Vegas golden
knights will be back home on Tuesday for
game five facing what could be their
last game in the Stanley Cup Final if
they come out Victorious reporting here
in Summerlin Madison Kimbrough 8 News
Madison sure had a fun day great out
there thank you so much before